what if i told you that the earth below
you is moving
you'd probably say of course it's moving
we're standing on a planet that's
spinning on its axis while revolving
around the sun at about 107 000
kilometers per hour and on top of that
our whole solar system is circling the
center of the milky way galaxy but
there's another kind of movement that
happens slowly in the rock beneath your
feet
earth's lithosphere which is made up of
the crust and the upper part of the
mantle is broken up into pieces called
tectonic plates
these plates move around on top of the
asthenosphere which is the section of
the mantle just below the lithosphere
don't bother racing a tectonic plate
because your victory would be guaranteed
tectonic plates typically only move a
few centimeters in a year which is about
as fast as your fingernails grow
however after millions of years those
distances add up
this means that the earth hasn't always
looked the way it does now scientists
believe that the continents were once
all connected in one big supercontinent
called pangaea just imagine if the
continents were still connected today
you could drive from africa to
antarctica or even take a train from
south america to europe
over 200 million years pangaea broke
apart and the pieces drifted into the
continents we know today
so if the plates move so slowly
how do we know that they move at all
scientists have documented evidence from
various features on earth that support
the theory of plate tectonics
if you cut out the consonants on a map
you can see that they almost fit
together like a jigsaw puzzle for
example the east coast of south america
looks like it could fit into the west
coast of africa matching or
complementary coastlines is one piece of
evidence that continents were once in
different locations another piece of
evidence is that scientists have found
fossils from the same species on
different continents
there's no way those land organisms
could have traveled across the ocean
this suggests that the animals lived
from the continents were connected
and the plates are still moving slowly
but surely to this day
but they aren't all moving in the same
direction a plate can collide with one
plate move away from a different plate
and slide past another we categorize the
ways plates interact at their edges as
having convergent divergent or transform
boundaries
con is a latin prefix meaning together
so convergent plate boundaries are
places where two plates come together
let's take a look at an example of a
convergent boundary where the indian
tectonic plate collides with the
eurasian plate
the crust of the plate becomes
compressed and the indian tectonic plate
gradually moves under the eurasian plate
however the lower density of the crust
keeps the indian plate from sinking back
into the asthenosphere all the way
this lifts up the eurasian plate and
creates the himalayan mountains
these mountains are some of the highest
in the world and they include mount
everest which is the tallest mountain
above sea level
and the two plates are still colliding
this causes the himalayas to grow by
more than one centimeter each year
another kind of plate movement is called
a divergent boundary
the dye in divergent comes from a latin
prefix meaning apart so divergent
boundaries happen where two tectonic
plates move apart
divergent boundaries can create
different kinds of landforms like rift
valleys and mid-ocean ridges
the third kind of plate boundary is
called a transform boundary or transform
fault and it happens when two plates
slide past each other
okay maybe slide isn't the best word for
it because the plates don't move in one
continuous motion you can imagine when
two incredibly large bulky rocky things
move past each other there's a lot of
friction
pressure builds up between the plates
and once it gets to be too much the
plates slip and release the pressure
this motion causes earthquakes and you
might be wondering what causes plates to
move well scientists are always learning
about the earth since the earth is so
complex although earth's internal heat
may play a small role more evidence
shows that gravity is key
tectonic plates are solid and they're
denser and cooler than the asphenosphere
because the asthenosphere is also pretty
solid the plates rest on top of it
however the asthenosphere is so hot that
it can behave a bit like clay this means
that at convergent boundaries the edges
of the plates can sink into the
asthenosphere a process that is driven
by gravity
so even though you'd win in a race
against a tectonic plate the plate will
still keep on moving millions of years
after you've declared yourself to be the
winner